Good morning everybody. In the
last couple of lectures, uh,
we have looked at what happened when
Rome took over civilizations that were
older then Rome zone and arguably
even more advanced than Rome's own.
And what happened of course,
was an interesting mix
between the architecture and
the architectural forms that
the Romans brought with them and what
they found in these highly developed
civilizations.
And the interesting mix that
came about because of that.
But we've also taken a look at,
uh,
at what happens when Rome went out and
created cities essentially from scratch
built cities where there had been
no cities before. Uh, and uh, and,
and what happened as a result tended
to be cities that look very much,
uh, in the Roman stamp. And we're going
to look at a number of those cities today,
uh, in the western provinces
of the empire. In fact, uh,
to see what happens again,
when Rome build cities from scratch
in that part of the world. Uh,
and as I mentioned already,
the distinctive stamp,
this distinctive Roman stamp that
they had, but at the same time,
there is always some impact
from the local civilization.
And to mention in passing that at least
in the part of the world that we'll be
concentrating on today,
especially in goal ancient Gaul,
the Celtic tribes, uh, we're,
we're, we're foremost they are.
And we do see that some of the impact of
those tribes makes itself felt as well
as tribes, uh, in other parts of
this part of the ancient Roman world.
Just as a reminder,
I want to show you again a couple of the
monuments that we looked at last time
when we were talking about Greece
and about Athens under the Romans.
And I remind you,
for example,
on the left hand side of the screen
of this temple of Olympian Zeus,
the Olympia,
he aeon in Athens,
which was begun already
in the archaic period.
The Greek archaic period continued
to be built up are those,
the patrons tried to complete it in the
course of the Hellenistic period into
the Augustan period. And
ultimately, as you'll remember, uh,
it was completed under
the emperor Hadrian.
So a building with a very long
history and a very distinctive style.
And when it was completed
under Hadrian of course,
you'll recall that it looked entirely
Greek, very similar to what it had.
It would have been, uh, in the Hellenistic
period. Uh, so those, again, the,
the Greeks holding very
tenaciously to their own plans to,
they are building materials and
indeed to the kinds of artists,
architects and artisans to carve them
that that had been carving them for
centuries.
We also took a look at the building
on the right hand side of the screen,
which is the oral Ogi on event drawn
like this or the tower of the winds.
And you'll remember in this case that
the civilization that had impact on was
another, uh, firmly entrenched
civilization. And that is that of Egypt.
We talked about the fact that while the
date of this monument is controversial,
uh,
we'd might be second century BC,
it might be [inaudible] or even into
the Augustan period. It's controversial,
but we talked about the fact that
even though the date is controversial,
that the monument itself was built under
very strong influence from Ptolemaic
Egypt. Uh, the Ptolemaic Egyptians
particularly intrigued, for example,
by clocks. This was a water
clock, as you'll remember,
a and by these abstruse,
uh,
I identifications of abstruse
wins a male winds, uh,
that we see in the upper most parts.
So again, the impact of two very,
very high civilizations,
a Greek civilization and the Egyptian
civilization on Roman architecture in the
eastern part of the world. Today
we're going to go west, uh,
and we're going to look at Roman
architecture in a variety of places,
including a and some beautiful places,
including the south of France,
uh, a series of cities. And I'll
point those out to you in a moment,
uh, in the north of Italy. So the north
of Italy, the south of France, into Spain,
into what is now Spain. And
then also we will dip into, uh,
an area called Istria, which is the
upper most part of what is now Croatia,
where a place by the
name of Pola is located.
So those western provinces will be,
are the area that we're going
to concentrate on today. Now,
any of you who've traveled in this
part of the world know that it is
extraordinarily beautiful.
Uh,
and I show you just one example of that.
When you go along the French Riviera,
for example,
I,
you see places as sophisticated
as Monte Carlo with its yachts,
Mort here, uh, and of course
with its glittering nightlife,
and it's extremely famous, uh, uh, casino,
the Casino in Monte Carlo.
There are also other wonderful
cities to visit along here.
Modern cities such as that, a veal
frosh, uh, which you see here. And it's,
it's a fabulous pastel colored houses
with boats that are not quite as
magnificent as those at a Monte Carlo,
but nonetheless, very picturesque,
a wonderful place to visit.
So it's not a hardship to have
to travel and look at, uh,
at Roman antiquities
in the south of France.
I want to begin though with northern
Italy, with a city in the north of Italy,
uh, city, uh, at a place
called [inaudible] stuck.
So the first on your monument list
for today, uh, a city, uh, that was,
that was founded by the Romans
in 24 BC in the time of Augustus.
And therefore, it won't surprise
you to hear that it's ancient.
Roman name was Agusta Pretoria.
I boost to Pretoria,
the modern city of a asta.
And it the last colony that
the Romans founded in Italy,
the last colony. And it's
interesting to see, therefore, uh,
that this last Roman colony in Italy takes
almost exactly the shape of the first
Roman colony in Italy.
You'll remember the city of Ostia,
which the Romans founded in 350 BC,
and the way in which it conform
to the typical cost from plan.
We see the same thing here.
Uh,
we see this typical costume
plan for a Asta, a rectangle,
a regular rectangle laid out.
According to Roman surveying practice,
we see that the two major
streets of the city,
the carto and the deck
[inaudible] meat in the center,
and that at that intersection of
those two main said to a main streets,
we see the location as it
should be of the forum.
Most likely you'll see a question mark
there. So we're not absolutely sure,
but we think that the forum
was located there. Uh,
if you look around at
the rest of the city,
it was very regularly laid out with a
series of buildings that we've become
accustomed to seeing in
a typical Roman city.
When a typical Roman city
is built from the basics,
you see the boughs here, you see a temple
up there with a crip deport this, uh,
you see a theater and you see an
amphitheater. This site, by the way,
spectacularly located in the Italian Alps.
Uh,
it's at the intersection of two major
trade routes in the Saint Bernard passes.
As you can see from this plan
that comes from Ward Perkins.
And what you can also see that's typical
of these cities that the Romans built
from scratch, uh, around the
western part of the empire, uh,
is the fact that the city
is ringed with walls. Uh,
and that it has a series of gates,
the openings of which you can
also see in this excellent plan.
Now I can show you also a
from the city of a Asta,
a surviving Roman arch, one
of those gateways in fact, uh,
from the city that we know dates to the
age of Augustus. So we give it a date,
the same day, roughly 24
BC. You see it here. Uh,
you see, if you remember, uh,
the arches that we've discussed from the
Augustan period in the past, uh, you'll,
you'll note right off that this is
very consistent with other, uh, uh,
Bustin arch design.
By that I mean it has one
single RQ weighted bay in
the center flanked on either
side by pedestals,
wide wide pedestals that have a set
of double columns on either side.
As you can see here,
uh,
the major difference between this and an
arch that might've been put up in Rome
at the same time,
uh,
in the Augustan period is the fact
that it is made out of local stone,
which is characteristic of so much of
provincial Roman architecture and will be
the case for most of the buildings
that we look at today. Uh,
the attic is gone. There's a modern
roof on top of the structure,
the ancient attic is gone.
But you can imagine that it would have
had a fairly traditional attic with an
inscription at the apex and probably
some kind of sculpture crowning,
uh,
the monument in antiquity.
Now there's one detail that has to do
with the orders that are used here,
uh, that is different from any
other arch that we've seen before.
And I wonder if any of
you notice what that is?
The columnar orders.
Okay.
They are what?
Doric ionic Corinthian Corinthian.
Okay. Everyone agrees that Corinthian,
you're absolutely correct.
Uh,
but what is strange about the fact that
you look above those Corinthian columns?
What do you see? That doesn't
usually go with Corinthian columns.
Okay.
The try glyphs in the metaphase,
the triglyceride, the metal piece,
it's tend to accompany the doric order.
So this is very interesting.
We see this mixing of the
orders here, uh, the use of,
of Corinthian columns, but a doric
freeze with try glyphs and metaphase.
You'd never see that in Rome
itself. Uh, but what it is,
is an interesting playing around with the,
uh,
with the canonical orders that have been
passed from Rome to this part of the
world. This particular architect
or patron or the city itself,
but whatever was the patron
of this particular monument
made the decision to go
into somewhat different routes.
So an interesting mixing of the orders
and eccentric a arch in that regard,
but in every other conforming quite
closely to what we would see in, uh,
in Rome, the city of Rome
contemporaneously. Uh, we,
we,
I also,
I wanted to go from a asta in the
north of Italy to the south of France,
to provost,
uh,
to take a look at the original
town plan of the city of Rl,
the well known city of Rl. And those of
you who know it or have been there? No,
it probably primarily as the
city of Vincent Van Gogh. Uh,
it's in the city of RL. He
spent a good deal of time, uh,
he went to this particular cafe so often
that it bears as bear born his name,
uh, for some time, the cafe van Gogh.
And you'll see another view of a lovely
Piatsa in the city of our plaza in the
city of, um, of Rl a.
And then the famous painting of Van
Gogh, the painting that he made, uh,
of this particular cafe that he used
to spend so much time in a cafe. Again,
as you see here is still
there. Uh, and when you,
where you can yourselves go and
sip an Aperitif or whatever,
uh, this part of this, the city of RL,
wonderful place to go. It has a very,
I'm not going to show
it to you in any detail,
just a glimpse here of
it's a famous amphitheater.
It has a very well preserved
Roman amphitheater and
the fact that France is so
close, as you can see in that map I
showed you before, uh, to uh, Spain,
uh, has, has, uh,
led to quite a bit of Spanish influence
coming into this particular part of
France.
Uh,
and this amphitheater is used today not
only for other kinds of performances,
but even for bull fights. Uh, as you see,
this is actually bullfight in Madrid,
not in a, not in, um,
oral. Uh, but nonetheless,
it's a sort of thing that has been
performed even in the amphitheater at RL.
Here's the map again,
before I show you the city plan
of oral as it would've looked,
I just wanted to remind you of these
towns in relationship to one another.
So we've,
we've come up from Rome.
We've looked at [inaudible] in the
north of Italy, in the Alps, a,
we're making our way now
into the south of France.
And I wanted to point out the proximity
of northern Italy with the south of
France because we do believe,
uh,
that a lot of the impact of Rome was felt
through the intern on south of France
or what is now the south of
France was, was, felt, uh, uh,
through was passed through the
intermediary of the north of Italy.
That there was certain
kinds of architectural forms
that were developed in the
north of Italy,
uh,
that were transferred into the south of
France because of the proximity of one
to the other. We're going to be looking
at RL. We're going to be looking at name.
We're going to look at a building and
locked tour B. We'll be looking at seven,
me and at orange,
the great theater at orange as well as
a temple at van. So all of those sites,
we're going to dip into Spain. Uh,
we're going to look at a famous,
famous,
spectacular aqueduct of Segovia and a
less spectacular but very WellPreserved
aqueduct at Terra Gona. Uh, and then
we're also going to make our way,
as I mentioned before, into Istria, uh,
part of what was formerly Yugoslavia
to this site called Pola. Uh,
that is now in, as you know, Croatia.
I want to begin with the, uh,
with the city plan of RL, uh,
as it would've looked in ancient times.
And I show you here the city
plan, uh, of the, uh, excuse me,
not the city plan.
I want to show you the forum to give you
a sense of what fora looked like in the,
in the western provinces, uh, during
this period, especially in Gaul.
I want to show you the forum
plan of the city of Rl a.
And I show it to you here with the
modern streets super imposed on top of it
because much of it is underground,
you can't see too much of it today,
but it has been explored underground
enough where scholars have been able,
archeologists have been
able to reconstruct the fact
that it was a large open
rectangular space surrounded by columns
as we have seen is characteristic of all
Roman,
uh,
as forum design from the time from the
forum and palm pay that we looked at very
at the very beginning of this semester.
And although you can't see
it on this particular plan,
there was also a temple on one short
and as well as a basilica that was part
this plan. And I think it's interesting
to think back, especially as you review a,
from what we'd done sit from the
midterm through the second midterm. I,
it's interesting to think about a
basilican architecture and because it was
usually a part of forums and
when it was a part of, and,
and in what buildings in what
fora it was incorporated.
Think back to Pompei a think
to the forum of Trajan in Rome.
But think of the fact that both the,
the forums of Julius Caesar and the
forum of Augustus in Rome did not have a
basilica, is as part of them here
already in the Augustan period in a,
because that's when this
dates in the Augustan period.
We see a basilica incorporated
into the forum plan, uh,
in what was ancient goal.
Uh,
I mentioned that there's a well
preserved as a WellPreserved crypt.
Deported is an underground storage area
around the colonnade and you see a view
of it here,
extremely well preserved and it should
remind you of those crib deport a that we
looked at very early in the semester
at the sanctuaries that we explored the
sanctuary, you know,
actively and um, Hercules,
victor and Hercules, Victor
Tivoli and uh, Jupiter AG,
sir at Terra Cina for example, very
similar with its barrel vaulted carters.
This one was used for
storage within the forum,
so they would store salt and fuel,
uh,
and other items that they
would need for daily use. Uh,
but it also became eventually,
and you can get an inkling of
that from this view on the left.
It eventually became a dump,
a for architectural members that were
no longer needed. As you can see here,
columns and capitals, but also for
sculpture. And one of the most famous, uh,
portraits of the emperor Augustus was
found in this crypto porticas dumped there
at some time,
some later period.
And it's now on display in the
archeological museum in RL.
I want to turn now to the
theater at all wrongs,
which is one of the most
spectacular monuments that
I'm going to show you today.
And you see it in this
extraordinary view from the air. Uh,
a building that you can see from your
monument list was put up in the late first
century BC or early first century.
And it is really something special,
not only in its own right, but also
because of how well preserved it is.
And you can see in this view,
uh, not only the typical,
the typical scheme that we have seen
as we've become accustomed to for Roman
theater design, the semicircular
orchestra, the semicircular Cabiya,
the division into these wedge
shapes, sections or Kunae, uh,
the, uh, the outer wall of the structure.
And you should be immediately struck by
this outer wall of the structure because
the outer wall of the structure is better
preserved than any other outer wall
that we've seen in the
course of this semester.
It's preserved to its full
height. It is very severe. Uh,
but that severity would have been lessened
in antiquity by the incorporation of
a colonnade on the front of the structure.
Uh,
so this very important building,
uh,
in that regard because we again have
this very well preserved wall which gives
us a good sense of what these walls
would have looked like in antiquity.
And you have to imagine here,
uh, the, um, again that,
that alleviation of this,
of this severity by that portico.
You can also see here though something
very interesting about this particular
theater, uh, that, uh,
that makes it connected.
Although it's Roman in every way,
uh,
that connects it also to earlier
Greek theatrical architecture.
Because you'll remember that the major
difference between a Roman theaters and
Greek theaters was that Romans built
their theaters on their own hill made of
concrete, but the Greeks built
their theater is on hell,
actual natural hillsides.
And if you look very carefully at this
excellent view from the air, you will see,
uh,
the way in which this particular theater
at [inaudible] is actually built into a
hillside.
They happen to have a natural hillside,
perfect for this kind of construction
right where they wanted it to be.
So they took advantage of
that hillside and they place,
they supported the Kavya of
this structure by that hillside.
As you can see,
extremely well,
the interior of the theater at [inaudible]
is also extremely well preserved.
As you can see here. Uh, you can
see the, uh, this, this stage,
uh,
you can see the semicircular orchestra,
you can see the stone seats of the Kavya.
Uh,
and you can also see that the stage
building and because the wall,
the outside retaining wall
is so well preserved. Uh,
you can also see that the interior
of the wall still stands, obviously.
Uh,
and this wall had one giant niche in the
center with a projecting element also
in the center, and then would
have had three tiers of columns,
one on one on top of one another.
Most of those are
unfortunately no longer there.
But you can see one set of two pairs here.
Uh,
one of the lowest tier with two columns,
the upper tier with two
partial columns above that,
which gives you some sense of what this
would have looked like in antiquity.
Again, we think the tears, the
columns were on three stories. Uh,
remember the date of this lake
for century BC probably. Uh,
and so this does post date some of the
60 to 50 beef to 40 BC paintings that we
looked at that show these
kinds of multistory skein.
I frons is with a columns we taught.
We speculated about the fact that some
of those may have been based on actual
theatrical architecture, but that it
didn't survive from that early on,
but it made,
it may have been made out of wood.
But here we see a fairly early example,
uh,
in the Augustan period
in the south of France.
And it is very important in that regard.
I want to turn from theater architecture
in the western provinces to a temple
architecture. And just as in
Rome, and just as in every
city that we've looked at,
temple architecture was
extremely important. Uh,
the temples that I'm going to show you,
and I'm going to show you two of them,
one at Vn, uh, in France
and one at a Neem,
also in France are among our best
preserved Roman temples today.
Uh,
and it's important to keep in mind that
both of them were part of complex as
they stand in isolation today.
But in antiquity,
they were part of a complex,
uh,
probably some kind of forum or
central space for that city.
Uh, this is the one that van which
I show you, show you to you first,
that dates,
uh,
to the probably to before a 14,
and it is a temple that was
put up to Augustus in Roma.
It may have been the dedication may have
been changed to Augustus and his wife
Livia. Uh, at some point
we're not absolutely sure,
but you see it here in a very good
general view of what it looks like today.
It's one of these buildings that has been
preserved in large part because it has
been used for later purposes.
It was used as a, as a marketplace. Uh,
it was used as a museum at one point and
that is what has helped to preserve it.
We see it again here.
And it's interesting I think to compare
it to the restored view of the temple of
Mars old tour that was part of the forum
of Augustus in Rome because the dates
are roughly comparable to one another.
And I think that you will see that it is,
that it is atypical Roman temple,
in fact,
almost indistinguishable from what we
would see in Rome. At the same time.
So here's an example again
of what happens when you go,
when the Romans go into a part of the
world that isn't already inhabited by a
very highly developed civilization
that they make buildings that look very
similar to those that were put
up contemporaneously in Rome. Uh,
the temple at the end is no exception.
If we look at this temple,
we see it has the typical
Greco-Roman plan, uh,
with the tall podium,
the deep porch,
the freestanding columns in that porch.
Uh,
and we see that the order that is
used here is the Corinthian order.
Some of the temple is made
out of local limestone. Uh,
some of it is made out of marble.
Uh,
but what we see here
that's very interesting.
Visa vi what was happening at the
same time in Rome is the seller.
You can see that the sella
is actually very shallow,
much more shallow than the
cell cell a usually is.
And you can see that quite
well in this view over here.
And that same shallow seller we find
at the temple of Mars all tour in Rome.
The other similarity is the fact that
at the Temple Marzel tour in Rome,
we have freestanding columns,
columns all the way up to the,
to the back here, uh, and
those columns and the,
and the space between those
columns and the wall of the Sella.
And that creates a tie,
a type of temple design that we referred
to today as a temple with ally or
wings, wings, one on either
side of the seller, uh,
formed by that space between the wall of
the Sella and the freestanding columns.
And we see exactly the
same thing over here.
This design of a temple with all lie,
there is no question that this temple in
Vienne was built under the very strong
influence of the temple
of Mars old tour in Rome.
All of those features,
I mean,
it wouldn't have come upon
those features by accident.
It is clearly being closely based.
One on the other here are two more
views of the temple of uh, uh,
of Augustus and Roma Slash Livia at van
where we see all of the features that
I've already shown you.
But where you can see particularly,
well the shallow seller, uh, the plane,
the back wall here that has
pilasters rather than columns.
And then if you go around the back, you
will see it as a flame plain flat back,
uh, which was the case also for the
temple of Maura's old tour in Rome,
a more famous temple and
even more famous temple.
And if that's possible and even better
preserved a temple a is the one that you
now see on the left
hand side of the screen,
which is the famous Meson cafe at Neem.
It to it to,
uh, has been reused in ancient
times as a museum and the like,
it's still a small museum today,
which is one of the main reasons
that it is so well preserved.
It is an extraordinary
work of Roman architecture.
I think it's interesting to compare it
to the Temple of Port Tunis that we saw
much earlier this semester. The major
difference of course between the two,
the materials that are used,
this is local limestone with marble.
Uh, this, well we won't,
we won't remind ourselves,
but the Tufa and travertine and so on and
so forth, uh, that we looked at earlier.
This is an ionic temple.
This is a Corinthian temple,
but once again, it seems to be
the temple of Mars old tour.
That was the main model,
uh,
for the Meson cafe or the
square house at name. Uh,
and I show you another view of it here
because you'll see just like the temple
of Port Tunis,
it has a pseudo peripheral colonnade
and you can see that extremely well.
Yes, the columns and
circle the entire monument,
including the back wall.
Uh,
but those columns are engaged or attached
to the wall going all the way around
here.
You can again see the opas quad rotten
blocks of this local limestone that's
used for the walls and then marble use
for the columns and also for the capitals
of this glorious and very well preserved
Roman temple and hear some spectacular
details of the capitals of the,
uh,
of the temp of the Meson cafe at
Neem and the freeze and also the,
uh, the decoration up above. And what's
interesting about these capitals,
if you look at them in detail,
you will see that not only are they
Corinthian and we can see the uh, the, uh,
spiral volume it's growing out
of the canvas leaves down below.
But if you compare these
capitals to a capital,
a preserve capital from the
temple of Mars old tour in Rome,
you will see that not only
are these based on these,
but that they are so close,
so close that there is absolutely
no question, I believe,
well this was not suggested by me,
but by a scholar who studied
these in great detail, uh,
and determined and suggested and all
of us have believed it ever since,
that these are not only based on those
but that the same workshop a worked these
capitals for the Meson cafe as for
the temple of Mars old tour in Rome.
Now that works well chronologically
because you'll remember that the temple of
Marzel tour in Rome was dedicated into BC.
This building,
as you can see from your monument
list, was built in around a d five. Uh,
so there was perfect. That was, it
was perfect timing for those, uh,
architects and artisans who had been
successful at the temple of Marzel tour in
Rome. This major commission
allowed themselves, we believe,
to be hired out to those in the
south of France to make the trip,
uh,
to name a,
in order to build a temple in the model
of the temple of Mars old tour in Rome
at name, uh, the result, the
Meson cafe. Uh, so this, this is,
I've made this point, uh, in other
lectures about the fact that, uh,
there are certain times when
we can document not only
the exchange of ideas but
even architectural ideas,
but even the exchange of architects
and artisans going from one part of the
Roman world to another
in search of commissions.
And this is one of those times where
we can document with certainty, uh,
that artists working in the
employ of the emperor himself.
Augustus made their way to the south
of France to create this amazing temple
from scratch.
Once again,
temple very much in the model of the
most famous temple of its day in Rome.
And that is the temple
of Mars old tour in the,
in the forum of Augustus.
One more detail.
Here's the Marzel torque capital
again, and overhear, uh, the,
the capitals of the Meson cafe
and I show you above the freeze,
which extremely well preserved
and you'll see this flowering,
a canvas plant that should immediately
remind you of contemporary decoration and
Rome. Think of the flowering
of campus plans of the aura,
pockets out boost die.
So once again,
a proof that there is a very
close connection to what's
going on in Rome at this
time.
And in the south of France.
Here's another spectacular view of the uh,
Meson cafe as it looks
in its location today,
uh, in the center of a plaza
surrounded by the daily life of name.
As you can see so well here,
uh,
it's still very much a part of daily life
and very interesting is the fact that
if you look across the
street from the Meson Cafe,
you see a building that was designed
by the very famous and very talented
British architect, Norman foster. Uh,
it's also a museum and it's a play on
the word on the name of the Meson Kallai.
It's called the Cafe Dar. Uh, it's
a museum that has modern art. Uh,
and it, it mostly exhibits
it's permanent collections,
but you can see,
and I'm going to show you a detail
in a moment to bring this point home.
You can see that Norman foster has
really looked at and studied, uh,
the Meson Kallai and has
created a modern version,
a very modern version of the Meson Kallai.
If you look at the Meson
cafe and it's, uh, it's,
it's deep porch and it's high
podium and it's single staircases,
facade orientation,
all the usual Roman elements.
And look at this building.
You will see that he too has created a
kind of portico, uh, in the front. Uh,
they're not actual columns,
uh, their, their peers,
but peers and it's very
slender and elegant peers.
But peers nonetheless that are clearly
being played off the columns of the Meson
cafe. And look at the way in which
he has done, uh, the, the, the,
the glass exterior.
He has divided it into a series
of panels that are clearly,
I believe reflecting, and I'm sure he
knew he was doing this at the time,
clearly reflecting the panels
of the Ashleigh masonry
of the walls of the actual
Meson cafe. So this very interesting, we
see not only dialogue happening, you know,
within Roman buildings themselves and
various parts in Rome itself and in
various parts of the world.
But this ongoing dialogue between
ancient monuments and modern buildings in
cities like Rome, there are pockets
in the Meyer building is one example,
but also in some of these other cities
like Neem in the south of France.
And by the way,
you can go up,
there's a roof garden that you can go up
to on the top of this kind of a Dar in
order to see a spectacular view
from above of the Meson cafe.
Now, one of the, uh, one of the
most important elements of Rome,
the Roman Ization of the,
uh,
empire was the fact that as the Romans
went in and built these new cities in
east and also in west,
they supplied it with amenities
that weren't there before.
And this was especially important in
the western provinces where again,
the civilization had not been all
that high, uh, prior to this period.
So the Romans come in and they build aqua
ducks with a vengeance in the western
provinces in the south of France,
in Spain,
in order to provide these
towns with a water supply.
And I want to show you a couple of
examples of our best preserved and most
spectacular Roman aqueducts anywhere in,
uh,
what was the ancient Roman empire.
I want to begin with perhaps the,
with certainly the most famous of these,
the so called [inaudible] also at Neem.
Uh,
and I show you first a map,
which gives you a sense of
what was going on here. Uh,
the patron by the way of the [inaudible]
at Neem was none other than Marcus
Agrippa. Marcus Agrippa, whom we've
talked about several times a semester.
The close friend,
confidant, a right hand man,
son in law that hoped for air of Augustus
who we saw was building buildings in
Rome. He built the bads that bear his
name, the best of the gripper, a anti.
You also built that first Pantheon,
that first temple to all the gods
were with its chorionic porch.
We saw that he was active
as a builder in Athens, uh,
where he built the Odi on of a gripper
and where he was honored with a statue on
top of a pier on the Acropolis in Athens.
He also was active in the south
of France as a great builder.
And it was here that he was responsible
for commissioning an aqueduct that would
bring water from 31 miles
away up in the mountains,
down to the city of name.
And this map gives you a very good,
a sense of exactly how that was done.
The source was up there at the top,
the top, uh, red, uh,
pink circle up there,
made its way all the way down
to the city of Neem here.
Uh, now the Romans were very clever
about how they built aqueducts.
They let gravity and the change in
terrain essentially do the work for them.
They tend,
they,
they placed a terracotta pipes underground
for the most part on sloping ground,
uh,
and allow the water to come from the
hillsides and the mountains down into the
city just as they did here on occasion,
they allow those terracotta tile of
those terracotta, uh, tubes to be,
to be carried by low walls.
But sometimes they got to a point where
they had to cross a body of water.
And that is exactly what
happened here. The River Gar, uh,
of the city of name of the
area of Neem, uh, goes through,
is located at this particular point.
And so aqueduct system
had to cross the river.
How did they do that?
They couldn't tunnel it underground,
that couldn't place it on a low wall.
So what they did was built a bridge.
They built a bridge to carry that
water across the body of water.
And the result of that
is what you see here.
This is the famous [inaudible]
at [inaudible]. Uh,
this is the bridge that serves
to carry the water across.
They place the terracotta pipes
in the aqueduct itself. Uh,
and that water is carried
across that aqueduct. Now,
what's particularly extraordinary about
this monument, besides that feat of,
of taking that, that, uh,
water across the river, uh,
is the fact that it is, well, if you
look at the building technique, you can,
you can tell that it is made of
Ashleigh Masonry, Ashleigh Masonry,
that is local stone in
this particular case,
as much as we have seen is the case for
the most part in architecture in the
south of France in the Roman period of,
but what is amazing about
this particular aqueduct,
besides this great engineering feat,
uh,
is the fact that the architects have
paid enormous attention to the exact
measurements, not only of the arch
itself, but of the occupations. Uh,
and they have, they have,
they have PE, they have, uh,
worked up all kinds of
elaborate art. Uh, uh,
mathematical theorems in order to get to
the point where they play these shapes
and the sizes of these shapes
well off against one another.
The larger occupations below are perfectly
mathematically worked out so that
they work well with the
smaller ones up above.
And we see in a building like this, I
think something that is really impressive,
not only a sign of Romantization,
I mean this is when you talk about Roman
imperialism and the Romans taking over
the world in ancient Roman times.
One could think about that in part in,
in a negative way. I mean, imperialism and
taking over and creating an empire, uh,
can,
can be viewed negatively.
But one of the positive things
that the Romans brought,
one of the many positive things that the
Romans brought to these underdeveloped
parts of the world was what we call
Romantization, bringing these amenities,
bringing things like water to a city
so that it could live at a higher level
than it was able to live before.
But besides that,
when you look at an aqueduct
liked the poem, do Gar at name?
I think you'll agree that although
we would call this a feat of Roman
engineering,
first and foremost,
the Romans have been adept enough
both through paying attention to these
mathematical considerations,
but also to carving the stone to making
the stone really work aesthetically that
they have essentially in this
aqueduct transformed, uh,
engineering into architecture into
what we would define as architecture.
I want to show you two other aqua docs.
Uh, the first two, both of them in Spain,
uh, the first at, uh, uh, uh,
Tarragona and the other one
at Segovia. Uh, first, uh,
a reminder of the fact that Spain is,
you'll recall,
was extremely important in the Roman
period because two of Rome's emperors came
from Spain,
I think of Trajan who was born in Spain,
born in Spain and also Hadrian
whom we see here on the left,
a map of Spain showing the locations
of Etol Ilica where a Hadrian was born,
but also the two sites that we're
going to look at Tarragona Toronto,
which was located very close to Barcelona.
You know, the sea as you can see here.
And then further inland Segovia.
So Govia which is near Madrid,
uh, the city of Madrid, I'm
so very accessible for any
of you traveling Spain. Uh,
these are sites that are extremely
accessible and especially Segovia.
Well worth looking at.
Just want to show you the aqueduct.
Did Tara go into briefly? Uh, you
can see it here on the screen. Um,
an aqueduct that dates to
the Augustan period and uh,
it is, uh, it's a handsome work
of architecture. Uh, it has, um,
Ashleigh blocks as you can
see, local stone. Uh, but
it doesn't have the finesse.
I think you can see here now how great
the polls do, Gar is because it doesn't,
it's attractive. It does the job.
It's a great engineering feat,
but it doesn't have the aesthetic,
the aesthetic values that DePaul do.
Gar Does, uh, with its, you know,
arches that are the same
size on the lower story.
And then in the upper story, uh, at, it
doesn't, it doesn't have the, um, the,
the appeal aesthetically,
visually that the Pont du Gard does,
but it does its job. However, uh, the art,
the aqueduct at Segovia
is quite another story.
The aqueduct at Segovia is right up there
with the palm to Gar at name as one of
the great works of Roman engineering
and of Roman architecture.
And what makes it all the more spectacular
is how much of it is preserved.
And I think you can see that extremely
well here in this amazing view of the
aqueduct marching,
you know,
making its way across the center
of the city of modern, uh,
Segovia and this truly spectacular image.
As you can see from your monument lists,
the date of the aqueduct of
Segovia is very controversial.
There are some people who
think it's first century,
there's some people who think it's second
century. I think it is most likely, uh,
to be,
uh,
second century and probably put up during
the time of Trajan the emperor Trajan.
But we're not sure about
that whenever it was put up.
It is an incredible example of aqueduct,
uh,
engineering and aqueduct architecture.
And it does allow us to see
a couple of things that we,
it's very distinctive in its own right.
It's beautiful,
but beautiful in a very different way
as we'll see from the Pont du Gard. Uh,
but it does allow us to look at a couple
of other features of Roman aqueduct
planning and design that I
think are worth talking about.
I show you here another view
of the aqueduct at Segovia.
Uh,
and uh,
your see you see here that it is for the
most part a two tiered aqueduct system,
uh, but what they've done here to vary
it and to make it much more interesting
aesthetically then the aqueduct in
Tarragona is to make those two stories
different in height. So the lower
story is much higher as you can see,
a with much more attenuated arches.
Uh,
and then the upper tier is
lower, uh, with, um, with,
with,
with much smaller arches.
The other thing that they've
done using local stone, uh,
they have left the stone in
a somewhat rougher state.
It isn't quite as rough perhaps
as Claudius is buildings,
but left in a fairly rough state,
which gives it a real
sense as you look at it,
of the texture of that stone stone,
of the materiality of that stone in a
way that makes this particular building
extremely attractive and impressive.
And you can see here this,
this view was also very helpful because
you can see people standing below,
which gives, it gives you some
sense of the very large scale, uh,
of this particular aqueduct.
Here's another view.
This is one of my favorite views
of the aqueduct at Segovia. Uh,
because I think here you can really get
a sense of the coloration of the stone,
of the texture of this slightly
rough stone and of the way,
even in the architecture of aqueducts,
again,
mainly an aqueduct is built mainly for
practical purpose to bring water from one
part of, of, of, uh, one
place to another place. Uh,
and to provide an amenity as we've
talked about it at a significant and
important day to day amenity. Uh,
but even with that, even with,
even though it essentially
a practical building,
aesthetics are never far
from the Romans minds.
And when this particular aqueduct is,
was designed,
not only did the designer have in mind
the texture of the stone and the way in
which the light of Spain,
this particular part of Spain hits
that stone at any given time of day.
But the whole concept
of Vistagen when you,
when you wander along this particular
aqueduct is it goes on for quite a while.
Uh, you can do that and you're not
on top of a body of water as well.
So you can walk along it down
below and see what you see as you,
as you meander through it. And it
is amazing aesthetically, again,
how they have set up a series of views
and vistas from one part of this aqueduct
to another. As you stand
here and, and you look at it,
look at it making its way, almost
marching. It's way, in fact, I,
I like to think it's Trey Janick because
it's almost like Trojans army marching
through the city of Segovia off too.
You know,
some military exploit in the far reaches,
uh,
because the way it marches through
the city as you can see here.
But all of these wonderful views
and vistas in Panoramas, uh,
that one can see depending upon
where one stands in the city,
where one stands beneath the
arches themselves is really
spectacular and clearly
was very much in the minds of
the architect who designed this.
Here's another very good view where if
you stand below the aqueduct and look up,
this is the sort of view that you see
with the rough stones even in the Balts of
the arches themselves. Uh, and,
and incredible work. And again,
the fact that it is well PR as well
preserved as it is, is really, uh,
something to be grateful for.
Here's a very interesting view because
it also shows you what happens with
aqueduct design. Uh,
when the terrain changes.
So in the center of the city,
then the views that we looked at just
before they were able to build the ground
level was low enough that they were able
to build the aqueduct and two stories
with that. Very high for a story.
And then the lower second story.
But what happens when the terrain
shifts when you go? Because again,
they're taking advantage of a source
that is located higher up with the hope
that gravity will do the work for
them and allow that water to, uh,
to flow from that source
down into the city.
And that is exactly what they did here.
The source is farther away and it's high.
So the,
so the water has to be piped into this
structure and make its way down from the
hillside to the city. So
you see the ground, uh,
rising here to go up that hill.
Uh,
and what happens is that they have to
adjust the aqueduct according to the
changing terrain.
So if you look at this particular section,
you will see that the bottom
story is just an arch. There,
arch rests on the
ground, uh, so that they,
because it has to be much shorter
at this juncture than anywhere else.
And you see the same eye.
Well,
you see it changing somewhat
here as it makes its way,
but you see it rounding the corner and
the way they have had to make these
adjustments and made them so well
and without losing the, the, uh, the,
the impressive aesthetic quality of
this particular structure. Once again,
a tribute to the fact that
these Roman architects,
we're not only great engineers,
but also without any question, uh,
world class architects. There's an
interesting monument that is located.
You can see the aqueduct of
Segovia in the back left there.
There's an interesting monument that was
put up to celebrate the by millennium
of the aqueduct in Segovia.
And it's interesting to see what,
what they put at the top,
the,
she will suckling Romulus and Remus to
underscore the close connections between,
um,
uh,
ancient Romans Segovia and a wrong,
another very interesting building in,
uh,
France is the one that I show you now,
which was a fountain, a
these aqueducts, you know,
these aqueducts brought not only water
for daily use, but fed fountains.
And I want to show you one fountain,
uh, from the, uh, from, uh,
Roman gall from France.
What is France today? Uh,
the so called Temple of Diana
wasn't a temple. It was a founder.
And as I mentioned that it
was built during the Hadrian
manic period between 100
and 130 what makes this
fountain particularly
interesting is if we just looked
at this, if I asked you if I put this up
and send you, what do you think this was?
A,
you would be unlikely to say a fountain
because you can see that this structure
is in the form of a basilica.
It's a barrel vault and central chamber
with side aisles that are also barrel
vaulted. You can see the barrel
vault of this side aisle over here.
You can see a barrel vault
of the central space here.
You can see that there
are columns on told basis.
You can make out over here that a
triangular pediment on top of a niche.
There were a series of niches along the
wall with alternating triangular and
segmental pediments. But most
interesting of all is the central, uh,
central space,
the central barrel vaulted space
with these barrel vaulted side Oz,
which is exactly the scheme of
a typical basilica. Uh, and it,
it's another example of something I've
shown you throughout the semester that
I've called the
interchangeability of form.
The way in which certain building types,
in this case a basilica built initially
as a civic structure for the trying of
law cases, uh, becomes a,
a plan that is used in other contexts,
whether it's in residential architecture
as we've already seen a and in this
case in, in the form of a fountain.
So that's particularly interesting.
Also interesting is the fact that although
this is a barrel vaulted structure,
it is made entirely out of local stone.
No concrete whatsoever in this
particular part of France,
no concrete stone construction.
It's a masterwork when you consider that
this was all done out of stone and done
extremely well. Look how smooth, uh,
the stones are. And look, the architect,
the designers have even been a talented
enough to create ribs with stone in that
stone barrel vault for
this amazing structure.
And you should be reminded when I talk
about the interchangeability of form, uh,
of the underground basilica that we
looked at way back when and the time of
Claudius, which was built
underground, made out of concrete, uh,
faced with Stucco as you'll recall,
but used for a secret sect. Uh,
and in this case,
the use of this Basilican structure
for a fountain in Roman France.
Up to this point,
we have looked at monuments that were
made possible by Rome's subjugation of
this particular part of the world.
Uh,
the subjugation we know of
at least a 44 Alpine tribes.
Uh, and so while all of these buildings
that I've shown you come because of that
subjugation and subsequent
Roman [inaudible] of the area,
there is one monument spectacularly
cited that actually celebrates honors,
that very subjugation. And it's to that,
that I now want to turn, uh, it is,
as I mentioned,
spectacular spectacularly
cited along the French Riviera,
not far from niece, not far from
Monte Carlo. Uh, you see it here.
It is the a trophy of Augustus.
The trope, pay him. I'll gousty is,
you'll see on your monument
list that is located in a,
in a town called lock tour B.
And you can see it rising up in the
midst of modern law tour. Be here.
It dates we believe to seven
to eight, two, seven, two,
six B,
c a and thus in the age of Augustus and
celebrates quite specifically Augustus.
And the inscription tells us this Augustus
is subjugation of 44 Alpine tribes.
Uh,
in this particular part of the world,
a monument put up to honor
that victory of Augustus.
So essentially a trophy monument.
You can see that it is only
partially preserved. Uh,
and I show you here a view of,
uh,
it down the street of the,
the modern street as it looks today,
uh, where you can see it
rising up over that street.
And if you look very carefully,
you will see that the stone that
the structure is made out of,
it's very similar,
in fact,
exactly the same as the stone
used for the local houses. Now,
this is very interesting because
what the monument, uh, did not look,
even though it's only partially preserve
today, even less of it was preserved, uh,
earlier on.
And it was in the 1930s that an American,
a patron decided that he
wanted to reconstruct the
as best that could be done,
the trophy monument at La Torre B
because there was recognition that the
monument at La Torre be,
had served as a quarry essentially
for the local inhabitants.
And the over the years they had been
taking the stone from the victory monument
of Augustus and using it.
That's why it's the same stone
using it in their houses. Uh,
and this American wanted to
rectify it. So he gay, he, he,
he donated the funds, uh,
that enabled them to take,
to tear down, to demolish 32 houses, uh,
and come up with 3000 fragments
from the Victory Monument,
the trophy at lock to our B,
and reconstruct it as best as
they could from those fragments.
And that's what you see there. Now,
here's a view of it as it looks today, uh,
as well as a model.
And what you can see from both of these
is not only the inscription and the
trophy in relief on this side that
mentions the 44 Alpine tribes,
but the monument itself and this model
makes it very clear what the general form
was, a round structure with
columns and circling it on a base.
And then the whole thing placed on a
very large and tall pedestal with a
pyramidal element at the top and a
crowning statue at the very apex.
This scheme of placing a rotunda on top
of a tall base is something that we have
seen as characteristic of funerary
architecture from the age of Augustus.
Think of the Tomb of Cecilia
Patella for example. Uh,
and it is that scheme that is used here.
So another example of this
interchangeability of form
that a form that was used
for a mausoleum architecture now used a
for a trophy monument of the same time,
uh,
but in a different part of the world.
The model also shows you that there
were niches around the, uh, central,
uh, circular structure. Uh, those were,
those had in them portraits of Augustus,
his lieutenants who have, who helped him,
uh,
placate this particular part of the world.
And then at the top of the step
pyramidal structure, a portrait,
a bronze statue of the
emperor Augustus himself.
Here's a detail of a law of law.
The victory monument at La Torre
be with all of those stones, uh,
from the, from those 32 demolished
houses. Reused here to reconstruct it.
We do, there is concrete used here, but
it's a Gallo Roman form of concrete.
You'll see in ward Perkins that he refers
to this work as putty at the high p e
t I t a p p a r e I l putty at Belle vie,
which is a essentially a gala Roman
version of concrete construction with,
with a stone facing that
little little work, you know,
little pieces of stone that are very
similar to opus and cared them but
different enough, uh, and,
and distinctively French,
enough to be called the putty
at Belle vie the victories.
Augustus is victories and pacification
of this part of the world also led to the
construction of arches.
And I want to turn to a couple of
those now. Uh, the arch at Sephora,
me also in the south of
France, you see it here. Uh,
it dates to around 20 BC.
Uh,
and it probably served as both an arch
in honor of these victories that Augustus
celebrated here, but also as a gateway
into the city. It's very simple.
It looks very much like we've come to
know Augustan arches are with a single RQ
weighted bay in the center,
uh,
columns in this case on two separate
bases, fluted columns there.
The capitals are not preserved so that
we don't know if they were Corinthian,
but they were probably Corinthian,
a very elaborate Archibold as you can
see here with the coffee [inaudible]
extremely preserved.
And then if you look very
closely at the decoration,
you see a couple of figures standing
on either side. These are actually,
they're headless now, but they're
actually figures of captives, of captives,
of local captives.
To make reference again to the
fact that this was military,
a military operation,
uh,
that allowed Augustus to take over these
to subjugate these 44 Alpine tribes.
Uh, and, and others in this
particular area, uh, and that,
that subjugation is referred to here,
uh,
by the representation of
those captured barbarians.
A much more important and more
interesting arch is this one a,
it's an arch that is located in um,
oh longish back to a home
also in the south of France.
The date of this monument
is very controversial and
I think by looking at the
general view and also a detail,
you can see why it is a triple bade
arch with a large central arch,
two smaller ones on either side
with columns on tall basis,
Corinthian columns in between them.
You can see that the central element with
its pediment projects into the viewer
space. You can also see that the, uh,
every inch of space is completely covered
with decoration, figural decoration,
piles of arms and armor from the enemy.
Uh,
so much show that it tends
to dematerialize the arch.
These are all characteristics
of later Roman architecture.
Think the arches Septum you severity,
which I'll show you again in a moment,
which has led some scholars to date
this as late as a d 200 or 82 oh three,
two oh four at the same time as
the arch of Septimius severities.
And it was long thought to be that also
because no one could conceive that this
idea of the triple bait arch could turn
up in let's say Augustan or Tiberian,
uh, France goal, uh,
at before it turned up in Rome.
So getting back to that issue of race
on several occasions about center and
periphery, does everything flow from
the center or are sometimes or forms,
sometimes developed in the periphery
and then make their way back into the
center is a, an age old and very
interesting question to ask.
But I think you can see
the reasons why a scholars,
some scholars have dated
this to the seven period. Uh,
here's the view and I'll say
more about that in a moment.
Have you here with a another
view showing an engraving,
giving you a sense of the
kind of sculptural decoration
that would have been, uh,
placed at the top, the
omnipresent, a figure in a chariot,
a four horse or warm in this case, four
horse, I think in this case, chariot. Uh,
and then, uh, figures of captured,
captured Indivi captured barbarians,
uh,
as well as trophies on the apex.
Here's our comparison
with the arch of CEP.
Timmy is severities and the Roman forum.
And I think you can see the close,
the close association between the two,
the triple bay,
the profusion of Decoration,
uh,
that we see in the arch on
the lefthand side as well.
Here's a detail of the attic,
uh,
which shows you an interesting battle
scene where the figures are very heavily
outlined as you can see
here, which is unusual. Uh,
scholars have suggested,
and I think correctly,
that the reason for that is that these,
these artists and this part of a goal,
we're probably working from copy books or
his copy scrolls, I guess I should say,
a drawings, drawings,
uh, of battle scenes,
typical Greco Roman battle scenes,
uh,
that they could use
Hellenistic battle scenes,
perhaps early Roman battle scenes
that Wa that they copied and they,
these were drawings and consequently
they copied them quite, quite,
quite exactly. Uh, by showing
the outlines, uh, around
the figures. It's one,
it's a speculation,
but I think it's interesting speculation
in this very frenzied battle scene from
the upper most part with regard
to the date of this monument,
though the plot thickens,
uh, one other detail. If you
look at the side of the art,
you see a,
an RQ weighted element inside.
You can barely see the
triangular pediment, but
there's an occupation inside a,
an unbroken,
a complete triangular pediment.
So that scheme of placing the occupation
and also tends to be a late feature.
However,
scholars who have spent a lot of time
looking at the sculptural decoration of
this monument, of the piles of arms and
armor, uh, that when finds there, uh,
which by the way includes piles of
arms and armor from a naval victory,
which is interesting as well as piles of
armor arms and armor from victories on
land,
which has made some scholars speculate
that this refers to a kind of generic
victory to victory on land and sea,
uh,
by whoever this honored but very
interesting is the fact that there is a,
a, a, um, some, some, uh,
there is one armament, uh,
that is inscribed with the name
sock grow. We're sac R o. V.
I R. SOC grow. We're a soccer. We are,
we know was someone who
is living and active, uh,
in the time of Tiberius.
He led a revolt in this part of a gall
in Aidy 21 against the local Roman
governor and his excessive
taxes. Uh, and uh,
it has been speculated that that Sacro
we're who is mentioned here is that very
same soccer. We're, uh, and that
it is very conceivable conceivable,
therefore, that this arch was put
up in the time of tybee areas.
I've given you a date of Aidy 25.
I believe that myself,
although it does defy,
you know,
define imagination to a certain extent
to think of an arch with all of these
features that I've described today as
early in the south of France as a d 25.
But it's something for you to think about
in terms of our whole question of the
relationship between a periphery
and, um, center and periphery.
I want to show you the last
group relatively quickly. Uh,
just to dip into a Istria is I said
I would to the upper most part of,
uh, of what is today Croatia
to look at one more arch, uh,
in a different part of the Roman world.
But during the same period,
the end of the first
century BC and arch at Polo,
I show you the location here of
a polo or pula at the very upper,
most part of Croatia. Very
close. Exactly at the Emmy's.
Just when I went there.
Once you're literally,
you go all across the border and
there you are, uh, the Italian border,
you're in Pola and you see the rest of
Croatia here with the other great, uh,
site of Split, which we'll
look at next time. Uh,
and of course the famous city
of Dubrovnik at the base,
you see the arch extremely well preserved.
Uh, another typical Augustan arch,
single Bayed, uh, two columns,
Corinthian order on a shared base.
Uh, if you look at the attic, the attic
is interesting. Local stone. Once again,
look at the attic, you'll see bases
that are inscribed at the top.
And those bases are very helpful in
terms of telling us something quite
extraordinary. And that is that this arch
was put up by a woman we know her name.
Salave'A Postuma, Salvia
Postuma, s a l V. I,
a p. O. S t, u, m,
a Salvia Postuma who put this monument
up to three male members of her family
who were involved in military
operations at this particular time, uh,
died. Uh, and then we're
honored by this monument.
I show you a reconstruction of what the
upper most part probably looked like
when there were statues of those
three male members of the family,
possibly in their military costumes.
Although we don't know for sure
at the apex of the structure.
Here's a detail of it. Also over here
where you see victories in the spandrels,
you see the Corinthian capitals,
you see cupid's carrying garlands,
all the kinds of decoration you see some
a Qantas leaves very much like those in
the our pockets,
all the kinds of decoration that have
been transported from Rome to be used,
uh, in, uh,
in this case in the north
of former Yugoslavia. Uh,
for this arch we see the Corinthian
capitals. Here we see the victories.
Here we see the cupids with
the garlands over there,
we see a chariot scene here.
Cherry had seen as interesting
reference to the race of life. Uh,
it referenced a victory and Athletic
Competition as well as victory,
uh, over, oh, you see the Ukrainian, they
are also clearly another touch of, uh,
roam of the RF pockets.
But this, this interesting,
we've seen this throughout the semester.
The close correlation in the minds of
the Romans between victory in battle,
victory in athletic competition,
uh, victory in the hunt, uh,
and also victory over death.
And all of that comes together
well in the our cheer.
If you look up into the vault, it's very
well preserved. And the center, uh, a,
a representation of an eagle with
a serpent holding a serpent, a,
this is probably a reference
to death and rebirth.
And remember this is Augustan and date,
so it predates the vault of
the arch of Titus in Rome.
But this whole idea of placing the vault,
a scene of death and rebirth leads,
ultimately I think to that
divinization scene of Titus,
I want to take you very
quickly, uh, to show you a,
an important tower tomb in
the city of San High. Me.
We're back in the south of France. Samurai
me, the ancient glom them g, L A,N ,
u m ancient Glonass, which was a
very highly developed town, uh,
also in the Greek period. So here we
see some overlay. We have local, local,
local, Celtic, custom, uh, the
Greeks were, were infiltrated here.
Then the Romans,
all of that piled one on top of another
to make a very distinctive city.
You can also see from the remains that
were extensive remains at them more than
most of these ancient,
uh,
French towns where you can see Babs and
temples and at parts of houses and Paris
styles and so on, quite well
preserved. I show you here for example,
some honorific basis as an altars and
overhear a hypo cost from one of the
baths,
uh,
looking very much like a hyper cost
we would see in Pompei of like date.
I also want to mention in case any of
you are making your way to the south of
France anytime soon.
It is located in the city of Glonass,
located very close to the
wonderful town of Lebo. In fact,
blonde is in the shadow of Lebo that
lies in the mountains on the top,
fabulous place to just wanted
nothing to do with Roman antiquity,
but just a great place to wander. As you
can see here in every one of the caves.
And there are a lot of them
have a places for wine tasting.
So it's a fun place to go. Here are the
two monuments we saw the arch already.
This is the tower tomb. These are
referred to by the locals as liaison,
teak liaison teak, the arch, the
antiquities, the arch, and the tower tomb.
And the fact that they
are in close proximity.
I mentioned the arch may
have well been a city gate.
The Romans always buried their dead
outside the city gate, city gate cemetery,
right outside extremely WellPreserved
tower tomb tower to him because it's
taller than it is wide.
This area of of France is particularly
famous because of Vincent Van Gogh.
Once again,
then go spend his last
years in an insane asylum.
As many of you may know in satisfy me,
this insane asylum, which you can see,
this is a van Gogh painting of that asylum
in which he spent those last days is
located exactly across the
street from liaison teak.
So if you make the pilgrimage,
they are,
I hope you'll make the pilgrimage
not only to see van Gogh,
but I hope that your aficionados,
and now I'm in fact,
I hope that you go to see liaison
teak and then also go to see, uh,
the asylum of Van Gogh.
Here's the monument of the Giulia Julie
attack a tower tomb that was put up in a
Samurai meet in 30 to 20 BC. Uh, so, uh,
a sort of the cusp,
the,
this late says area and into the
Augustine period and we think the Julie
represented here are in fact veterans of
Julius Caesar's Army who have taken his
name, Julius Caesar. All of his
battle, you know, is, is great. Uh,
military exploits in goal, uh,
referred to here by his veterans, uh,
who,
uh,
have taken his name and have settled
here on land that they were given in a,
in reward for their good work.
Again, it's a tower tomb,
a taller than it is wide.
A stepped base,
a Sokal with sculptural figural
freeze a quadra fronds up here,
Corinthian columns, and then at
the very apex [inaudible] loss, uh,
that has a two statues inside that Bolus.
This is pretty much the best
preserved Rome and tomb that we have.
Everything is intact here.
We believe,
remember I mentioned way at the beginning
that we think that a lot of these
Roman ideas came,
uh,
to the south of France via north Italy
and we think this was indeed the case.
North Italy in north Italy.
We know they put up a lot of these tower
tombs and we think it's likely that
this sort of thing imitates some of
those tower tombs in the north of Italy.
I show you a detail of two of the
figural freezes from the Sokal of the
monument,
which you can see represent battle
scenes and you can also see those deep
outlines just as we
saw at the orange arch,
which once again suggest to us that
these artists are looking at drawings of
this kind of thing that come from the
Greco Roman world and they are copying
what they see.
I don't have time to go into it here.
But if you look with care at some of
these, when you're studying this monument,
you will see the, you will see
that there are some figures, well,
for the most part, it makes sense. There
are some figures in this crowded seen, uh,
that don't work. For
example, here's a figure, uh,
on the ground with his
shield above his head,
trying to protect himself
obviously from a combatant,
but there is no combatant there.
And that seems to underscore again
that they are using copybooks books,
that they're looking at these things
that they're copying what they like.
They're copying the
scene for the most part,
throwing in some other figures that they
like that don't sometimes don't even
make any sense.
The detail up here of the thaw
loss with the two statues.
I spent about six weeks at
this monument at one point, uh,
and in that area at south by me and a
little, um, little place near, near,
near the liaison teak.
And I remember when I was there that
there was this wonderful, um, uh,
headline in the local newspaper that
said it was a huge storm with lightening
and so on. And the next morning
there was a headline that said,
has Gaius lost his head,
uh,
because the locals want to
believe that this is a monument,
not have local army veterans,
but of the Augusta and family.
And that the two figures that the upper
most part were Gaius and Lucia sees,
well, they were not Gaius
and Lucius Caesar, uh, they
were local veterans, but, uh,
nonetheless less the
myth has continued on.
And I want to show you lastly for just
a minute or so that remains to try to
underscore that point that the north of
Italy may have been a source for this
kind of tower two that
we see at sal by me, uh,
just by showing you one example,
it's by no means exactly the same,
but it's the best that I can do,
uh,
because most of these tower
tombs no longer survive.
But it is a thorough
loss tomb, uh, from, uh,
Aquileia and the north of Italy. The
dates to the early Augustan period. Uh,
and you can see that it has a large base
with a figural sculptural decoration
here. This isles of the blessed kind of
imagery with a full loss at the top, uh,
that includes a statue and
then a pyramidal roof, uh,
with a decorative element
at the upper most part. Uh,
and then as you can see,
some lions statues, uh, out
in front to guard. That too,
it's not by no means the same
thing as what I've shown you,
but it gives you is an idea that these
kinds of throw loss tombs on decorated
basis, uh, were popular
in the north of Italy.
And the idea may have made its way to
the south of France via these north
Italian examples. And lastly, uh,
just one last monument
because we've tended to be
looking at tombs in isolation,
individual tumors rather than tune complex
complexes because it's the individual
tombs and not the complexes
themselves that are well preserved.
But I want to show you one excellent
example from the north of Italy.
Again from this wonderful town called
upper layer and early Augustan, uh,
set of,
of alter tombs that are still preserved
in the actual original burial plots,
which gives you a very good idea of what
one of these plots would have looked
like. These are of course not
monumental tombs, but small, uh,
two markers in the shapes of altars.
Uh, and then other smaller, uh,
smaller items as you
can see very well here,
but it shows you the way in which the
Romans had the justice one has today a
these burial plots for the family,
these family burial plots that have
individual markers of different family
members in them and then has a kind
of a stone fence that in circles and
protects their plot. And you can
see that stone fence down here,
a stone fence that should immediately
remind you of some of the stone fences
that we saw in second style
Roman wall painting, for example,
that were omnipresent and second
style Roman wall painting.
And the last point I'll make today
is just to underscore once again,
I think there were lots of examples of
it today, the [inaudible], for example,
to throw loss, uh, and these fences as
well as the theatrical architecture.
We saw it all wrong. That
underscore, once again,
the closest association between
architecture and painting, uh,
from the republic,
uh,
all the way up to the
Augustan age and still beyond.
Thank you all.